i got so depressed like on like the
second third day i was miserable i was
so like what was it called cabin fever
that's what it is yeah yeah and like
where you were you just i i couldn't
even play games or watch [ __ ] because i
was just so like miserable you just like
lying in bed i was just like lying there
checking twitter and just like should i
do something no i'm too tired why
because i can't [ __ ] walk so i'm just
i'm literally just lying sitting down
all day he's just bed-ridden yeah and it
makes you feel [ __ ] awful like i
don't know it was terrible i know how
much sound like you're a little [ __ ]
and i'm sure everyone's going to say
that but i mean i i no i i saw the
photos some of the photos i'd thought
the same way it's one of those things
where when you see it and hear it you're
like doesn't sound too bad but then when
you do it you're like oh [ __ ] this is
really [ __ ] depressing yeah meanwhile
me and cindy were just like playing
games on like the big screen tv in the
living room and i'm just like it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] brilliant i'm like let's
pull out the ps5 we packed it
i didn't have a game console i tried
playing uh some games on my laptop but i
immediately was like oh this is not
comfortable yeah it's not comfortable
doing this yeah i don't know and the the
smell of my room was so goddamn bad it
was all the food yeah it was like
coagulating in the air yeah and my sweat
yeah but then like after reading a few
more posts and after like talking to
various people i think your health your
hotel quality experience is literally
down to chance well yeah because there's
three buses
when i notice there's three bus lines
and they all take you to a different
hotel and whichever one you go to uh you
get a different experience i think i
think our hotel was not just a business
hotel it was like it was actually like a
four-star hotel yeah and they put us in
which i'm saying sounds like it yeah
which i'm just like [ __ ] i got your
luck man
are on your side
you know i will say i know i i this is
kind of this i don't know i don't make
any more squid game jokes but this was
yeah when i got on the bus that we all
came on there was like half the people
on the bus right which means that half
of them got coveted
[ __ ]
the irish guy was there who i spoke to
and the old man was there
i was like
what's up
how you doing
so i saw that guy without his mask on in
front of like seven armed guards not
giving a [ __ ] and i was like damn man oh
my god what uh what day did you travel
on was it a date what day
oh what would you mean like was it like
a saturday like a friday and it was all
the same it was all it was it was all it
was awesome because what i will say is
that i uh like i traveled like right i
traveled on like a weekday so like not
many people were traveling so i feel
like i was traveling on
a friday maybe i don't know i mean yeah
friday's like a peak time for people to
travel i'm not sure you know i have to
have a look but yeah it was um because
like if you travel on the weekend i
think more people travel on the weekend
because i feel like
the worst hotels are for the are like
when there are too many people traveling
that it kind of like bleeds out yeah
because yeah i think we'd like there
we didn't have too many buses right
which is why like we i think we had like
one or two buses um and they all went to
the same place yeah so i i feel like
once that hotel started getting filled
out i mean if you think about it why
would you need to drive one and a half
hours for like because we flew in
through hanada which is like south right
yeah there's no reason to drive to a
hotel in the [ __ ] north
well they drove to the hotel and they
drove us back to the airport yeah and
then when you get to the airport you
have to have a
weird specific uh taxi you can't get a
normal taxi you can't book a normal taxi
it has to be a quarantine approved taxi
yeah right um and the problem is that
i didn't know what time we were leaving
no so how what time i should tell this
taxi i couldn't figure it out so i
didn't know so i i guess now to wait for
two hours at the canada and but the
thing was right is that so this whole
period has just been in quantity yeah
right they drop you off at canada and
they're like [ __ ] off
no no one checks you no one makes sure
and everyone just went went off and i
was like where's everyone going does
everyone know where they're going
i spoke to the irish guy who had um
who'd done it a few times and he was
like yeah you can just like chill around
the airport and wait i'm like well i can
just go to like the cafe and like
interact with people he's like yeah if
you want to and i'm like that doesn't
seem right i didn't i just stood in like
a corner waiting yeah away from everyone
i was like don't come nearby i'm sick
but i mean yeah i got it was [ __ ]
weird and it was
literally like that dude who's been in
jail life for most of their life trying
to assimilate back into society
it was [ __ ] weird and uh not very fun
experience and they've got rid of it now
for uk travelers oh really have they got
rid of them
no no they haven't okay oh they've just
they probably will soon they reduced the
quarantine time before we flew
uh i mean before we flew off to england
it was six days in quarantine hotel and
then they got halved to three days
six days in a hotel which is like six
days [ __ ] [ __ ] why couldn't he why
couldn't it be six yeah he would have
been around
a shiver that's all sending another day
there
it was nerve-wracking because the day i
had to do my test
they called me up and they said hey um
when you get your results if they're
negative you have to leave the room
right away so you have to pack just in
case you're you're
that you're leaving yeah yeah but i
didn't know and because someone on my
plane had been infected
there's a good chance that i could have
got it and uh yeah luckily i didn't but
like they called me up there like your
test results are negative please leave
the room as soon as possible and like
everyone's leaving and i was like what
the [ __ ] i gotta get out of the room
which is weird it was really a [ __ ]
experience don't recommend ign's 10 out
of 10 though yeah i i wouldn't recommend
that experience
my experience wasn't that bad oh yeah
you've got a free sweet hotel really
[ __ ] i remember conor like messaging me
every day like i could i knew connor was
like trying to say
i was like trying to drag something
negative about me and i'm just like i
mean amongst the [ __ ] yeah
honestly it's just it's pretty good
actually i'm i'm having a good time
you mentioned the next day being like
maybe this this day we'll get to yeah
i'm sure something bad happens
i went on twitter as well the day i
checked in
and a [ __ ] video from zed the musical
artist
was this [ __ ] had like a
penthouse suite somewhere like literally
a penthouse suite right yeah a bedroom
and
an insane you look at this
this is crazy
i'm ready
for the quarantine let's get it and bear
in mind japan isn't even giving out
visas right now to anyone but somehow he
got in he got a penalty in japan in
japan and he got a visa to get in
somehow because he's doing a concert but
somehow they made an exception and
people were not happy because there was
tons of people in the comments being
like uh zed you know that like students
haven't been able to enter japan in two
years yeah the [ __ ] and he's off here
showing his sweet and zed didn't even
have to do a quarantine for two weeks
only three days
yeah so after the quarantine hotel you
still have to quarantine at home for
about two weeks four four four years
for privilege
i was like that's a real privilege i
made a i made a joke because he gave a
room tour that was like two minutes long
of like all the [ __ ] different rooms
he had and all the [ __ ] he'd been sent
he'd been sent like everything you'd
ever need someone sounded like a gaming
pc for his quarantine and i was like
this is [ __ ] stupid this is the
stupidest [ __ ] i've ever seen
and uh i made a i made a parody video
yeah i was like hey guys here's my room
tour and i just turned the camera and
it's just like the room yeah and that's
the whole room yeah and i was just
joking
i was just joking about like how like
how like the difference compared to
rooms and then people got angry at me
being like you should be happy that you
even were able to enter japan you know
people haven't been able to enter japan
for two years the privilege your shirt
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] that was so annoying this
can't get adopted so i deleted the
tweets i was getting pissed off with the
replies i was like what the [ __ ] are
these reply and they're like why are you
blaming me don't blame me for lip for
being a resident in a country and
getting back in blame the [ __ ]
country for banning any form of visas
what the [ __ ] yeah exactly they feel
like taking it out on me i was like i
was getting so annoyed well i mean those
are humans those people couldn't [ __ ]
tweet to the japanese government right
yeah i was like
you're so lucky that you can re-enter
japan like i'm lucky that i can re-enter
the country i [ __ ] live in what the
[ __ ] do you mean shut the [ __ ] up
like what this is absurd like don't
don't don't try and say that i'm lucky
that is pretty unfair we're all we're
all unlucky that the government has some
shitty rules on this like don't don't
take it out on each other that's why i
got annoyed about it because
people are attacking other people who
are able to get into the country instead
of i don't know blaming the people who
are making the rules and these arbitrary
rules between countries yeah like in
america right some some states have to
quarantine but others don't yeah and so
there's this whole weird thing where
it's like
why i mean it's all one country right
yeah but it's yeah it's the same in
australia as well like most of the
states the like i mean australia had
that the [ __ ] worst though like
victoria i think was locked down for
like 280 days in a row yeah something
like that like no interstate thing like
my sister was like yeah i can't i'm not
allowed to travel more than 10
kilometers from my house yeah otherwise
i get fined but like but like there's
nothing stopping you from just
if you live in like so one of the
countries that was banned was like texas
you could just fly from the state the
state yeah
the state was country
uh the state of texas was like one
country that you would have to
quarantine in yeah um go to the hotel
for but there were other states you
didn't have to go to the hotel for how
weird so like why wouldn't you just
drive over to the next state and fly
from there and just say that you've been
there because there's no way they can
validate that yeah they can check that
right so to me it just felt really like
[ __ ] weird that but like covert has
shown that the the rules are not to do
with what's practical it's political
ties and yeah all those things if we've
learned anything and that's what is
shitty is that it sometimes feels like
you're just caught up in some inter uh
international [ __ ] politics of
countries that don't like each other and
countries that do like each other yeah
pretty much favoring i mean the uk did
it a lot too with countries as well
they've been pretty bad for it um it was
just a mess and i hated it and it's [ __ ]
well at least you guys got to you know
sit here with me yeah yeah i mean i mean
i mean like look at us you guys you guys
made it you made it